meet Frank and Daniel one day they
decide to go for a trip to Venice they
made a budget list for all their
expenses like residence flight Etc they
thought of making their bookings online
from a site that offered discounts to
the first 10 visitors on that day while
making their respective flight bookings
Daniel's transaction failed and he
missed the offer going on the other hand
Frank paid his share very quickly and
easily and became one of the three Lucky
Draw winners Daniel was surprised and
asked Frank how he could make the
transaction when Daniel himself could
not to which his response was it's
simple I used Bitcoin a type of
cryptocurrency
Daniel was confused and he asked what
cryptocurrency is and since when has it
been in use Frank stepped up and
explained to him cryptocurrency is a
virtual or digital currency that works
on blockchain technology and is designed
to work as a medium of exchange online
to buy goods and services and make
payments which was introduced to the
world first in 2013 By Satoshi Nakamoto
Daniel felt that it sounds similar to
other online payment options yes what
makes it so different
Frank explained cryptocurrency is
decentralized and free from any
third-party interference which means it
is not issued and controlled by any
government or Central Authority unlike
other payment systems that Banks or
governments are handling and that's why
a cryptocurrency transaction never fails
there could be many reasons for why
Daniel's transaction failed like he may
have exceeded his transfer limit for his
account must have been hacked or there
could have been some technical issue
with his bank server or maybe due to
high transaction fees imposed by the
bank but on the other hand
cryptocurrency charges almost no or very
low transaction cost there is no limit
for making transactions in fact you have
24 7 access to your money there is no
extra delay or extra charges on making
international transactions and the best
part is that anybody can use
cryptocurrency without the hassles of
paperwork all you need to do is create
an account on any digital wallet of
cryptocurrency this is what makes
cryptocurrency different from other
online payment options Daniel was
impressed by cryptocurrency but he
wondered how it works without the
control of an external Authority
upon research he found out that
cryptocurrency works on blockchain
technology blockchain is a set of blocks
that record information of transactions
like who made the transaction to whom
the amount of trade in the form of a
digital Ledger that is distributed
across the entire network meaning the
data is replicated and stored on each
node across the entire blockchain
network making it more secure and
impossible to change hack or cheat the
system then it is verified and validated
by every node to proceed with the
process of making the transactions the
crypto and cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography which is a method of using
encryption and decryption to secure the
data in the presence of any third party
with ulterior motives now Daniel was
completely aware of the whole technology
and concept behind cryptocurrency and
was influenced by Frank to adopt
cryptocurrency in his daily lifestyle
too he did that by booking his ticket
but sadly no discount
like Daniel cryptocurrency has
influenced and impacted an enormous
number of people worldwide due to this
increasing popularity new companies like
metoo and PayPal are coming forward and
investing in cryptocurrency every day in
2018 Malta an Island located in the
Mediterranean Sea south of Italy was
titled blockchain Island as it led to
the economic stability of the nation
many fintech companies like finance and
okx have already begun to take advantage
of malta's financial incentives and have
moved their headquarters to the
blockchain island
so here is a question for you which
hashing algorithm does cryptocurrency
use a script
B ethash
c
sha-256 d none of the above
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive Amazon
gift vouchers cryptocurrency is
revolutionizing finance and banking
around the world thanks to
cryptocurrency now anyone with an
internet connection can trade spend and
borrow money around the world and nobody
can stop them people like Bill Gates
co-founder of Microsoft Corporation and
Elon Musk CEO of Tesla support
cryptocurrency as it is much better and
secure than physical money and also
holds a great future for the world's
economy and on the other hand some
people think of cryptocurrency as a bane
to the world's economy like Warren
Buffett CEO of Berkshire Hathaway and
Ajay benga CEO of global MasterCard feel
that cryptocurrency is a platform of
criminal activities and will destroy the
world's economy well one thing is clear
that this conflict is going to stay put
for a little longer meet Susan an
aspiring painter she wishes to conduct
an online painting exhibition for all
her digital artworks however as the
exhibition is online she is worried that
her paintings won't be secure as anyone
could easily Forge or replicate them her
friend Mark came to her rescue with an
idea of nft he suggested that Susan
could buy nfts for all her paintings as
nfts are trustworthy easily transferable
and will also maintain her ownership
rights on her artworks
Susan had no idea what nfts were so Mark
stepped ahead and explained it to her
nfts turn your digital assets into one
of a kind by creating a unique digital
signature which defines the ownership of
your assets and that can be bought and
sold for real money cryptocurrency or
any other asset like a non-fungible
token AKA nft non-fungible tokens means
that they are not interchangeable and
each of them represents unique assets
owned by a specific person
on the other hand fungible tokens are
interchangeable and can be divided into
smaller units to form the same value for
example a 100 bill is fungible as you
can exchange it with five twenty dollar
bills or two fifty dollar bills but the
painting of The Last Supper is
non-fungible as it cannot be generated
in bulk even if it is copied it will not
be authentic each nft contains
distinguishable information like who
owns the digital asset and who sold it
making them distinct and easily
verifiable as it is impossible to forge
such a certificate it will secure her
painting's originality
after learning what nft is Susan was
curious to know how exactly nft Works
nft basically creates a blockchain-based
digital certificate for your digital
Collectibles including Games music art
and many more this certificate gives
your artwork A Unique identity the
underlying technology and the
programming language used by nfts are
the same as other cryptocurrencies such
as blockchain and the programming
language ethash or script nft majorly
exists on ethereum blockchain the
distributed public Ledger that records
all the transactions however nft is
quite different from these
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin and ethereum
are fungible tokens which means if you
trade Bitcoin or ethereum for one
another you will have the same value or
item in return basically money
on the other hand nft is a unique token
therefore if you try to trade it you may
end up with something completely
different in your hands crypto punks is
a remarkable example of nft it enables
you to buy sell and store 10 000
Collectibles with the proof of ownership
being stored on the ethereum blockchain
after exploring how nft's work Susan was
convinced and bought nfts for all her
paintings due to this her artworks were
secured from any kind of forgery and
also gave her artworks a particular
value this contributed to increased
sales too as everyone was easily able to
buy the artwork without any fear all in
all her exhibition was a complete
success
similarly nft has proved itself to be a
boon in the lives of many others like
Jack Dorsey the CEO and co-founder of
Twitter with his very first and famous
tweet just setting up my Twitter and
Vignesh sundarasen famously known as
medicoven who bought 69.3 million
dollars worth of nft art on people owing
to its increasing popularity people are
now willing to pay hundreds of thousands
of dollars for nfts nft has enhanced
media exposure and special perks for
aspiring artists like Susan on social
media this popularity of nft creates new
opportunities for new art platforms
motivating people to buy art from
internet platforms and promoting
copyright or originality of digital
assets
so here's a question for you what makes
any item non-fungible a exchangeability
b unique digital signature C tradability
D distributed public Ledger please give
it a thought and drop your answers in
the comments section below three lucky
winners will receive Amazon gift
vouchers many experts in the crypto
industry say that around 40 percent of
new crypto users will use nfts as their
entry point as a result of its growing
popularity nft could represent a more
significant part of the digital economy
in the future
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated here's your reminder to
subscribe to our Channel and click on
the Bell icon for more on the latest
Technologies and Trends thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
[Music]